J'en viens maintenant à notre prochain orateur qui est le
professeur jeune Marc jeune créature qui
a diverses casquettes y est en fait impliqué
je pense que vous pouvez expliquer mieux que moi
un organisme de recherche appelé carbone 4
et est un expert des questions liées à
la gestion du carbone  il est aussi à
l'ecole nationale supérieure ils veulent dire
le péri et membre de la
délégation française si je comprends bien à trois
des conférences des parties à
la convention-cadre des Nations unies sur les changements
climatiques il utilisera son expertise en matière de
climat dans l'énergie et dans  croissance économique
pour évaluer les risques d'effondrement et les
perspectives d'une économie à faible émission de carbone qui
est l'un des moyens que nous espérons pouvoir
éviter l'effondrement merci bien merci
beaucoup je suis retourné à l'école pour
cette petite robe parce que j'ai essayé  pour
répondre à la question, la réponse courte
à la question est non, nous n'allons
pas éviter l'effondrement systémique si nous
comprenons que le système s'effondre de la manière
de l'effondrement de la population mondiale  sur et
le système productif mondial et je
pense qu'ici dans votre EC D à part le
système économique le reste est un peu
secondaire donc nous n'allons pas éviter
l'effondrement systémique c'est ce que je
vais conclure à cause du vrai le très
la façon dont nous avons pensé notre système économique,
donc je vais aussi discuter de la
terre c'est la planète Terre c'est carré
et en fait elle a deux compartiments
parce que je le prends du point de vue de l'humanité donc d'un
point de vue humain d'un
point de vue humain ce qui est  la planète Terre c'est
un tas de ressources ok c'est juste un
panier de ressources c'est notre
vaisseau spatial ces ressources je les mets dans deux
tiroirs et - seulement celles qui se
renouvellent naturellement si on ne puise pas
trop vite dans ces ressources et celles qui
ne se renouvellent même jamais  si on ne rame pas trop
vite par exemple dans la seconde
t'as des minerais métalliques le jour où tu as
extrait des minerais de fer ou de cuivre de
la croûte terrestre le canon je veux dire et
ils ne sont plus dans la croûte et la
en th  e deuxième dans la première catégorie, vous
n'avez généralement pas de vent d'herbe,
quelles que soient les choses que nous savions si nous
voulions que nous ne l'utilisions pas trop vite, alors une
chose qui est absolument majeure pour moi
est que c'est le résultat de 40 milliards de
dons  en haut abandonner prendre un gâteau
un demi-milliard d'années pas grand chose à cette
échelle de temps depuis le Big Bang
et que l'évolution a créé pour nous une
planète gratuitement un océan gratuitement un
système atmosphérique gratuitement 30 millions d'
espèces plus ou moins gratuitement des minerais pour
combustibles fossiles gratuits gratuitement Je me souviens
qu'il faut cinquante à quatre cents
millions d'années pour former des combustibles fossiles, etc.
donc tout cela est gratuit maintenant personne dans cette
salle n'a payé un seul centime pour que le pétrole forme
du minerai de fer pour former un minerai de cuivre pour
forme d'un code génétique le code génétique
désolé des arbres pour former tout cela nous a été
accordé gratuitement maintenant vient l'
humanité et l'humanité va faire
quelque chose de très simple appelé production
et la production est en fait en termes de
flux physique est très simple nous  extraire les
ressources de l'environnement et les
transformer tout ce que vous voyez dans cette
salle tout ce que vous verrez dans votre vie
de la naissance à la mort les ressources naturelles
soit telles qu'elles sont sont transformées par
le travail des hommes au tout début nous
ne sommes pas très nombreux pas très productifs  donc
la quantité de ressources naturelles que l'on
puise dans les stocks renouvelables n'entrave pas
la capacité des stocks à se renouveler d'
accord les premiers pêcheurs
n'épuisent pas les stocks de poissons donc les
stocks restent homogènes mais le premier jour on
cueille des pierres dans le stock de  pierres le
stock de pierres diminue un peu à
l'époque ce n'est pas vraiment un problème donc on
peut continuer et un jour on découvre l'énergie
qu'est-ce que l'énergie du point de vue d'un ingénieur
notre point de vue de physicien
c'est en fait en utilisant un convertisseur en utilisant de l'
énergie en utilisant  et convertisseur
vous ne buvez pas d'huile et vous ne mangez pas de
charbon et je ne vous conseille pas de mettre
vos doigts dans la prise, donc
utiliser de l'énergie ne l'utilise pas pour
vous  Si, sauf quand vous mangez
au soleil, mais utiliser de l'énergie, c'est en fait
utiliser des machines et ce que vous devez garder
à l'esprit, c'est qu'utiliser de plus en plus d'
énergie, c'est simplement utiliser de plus en plus de
machines, ce qui explique pourquoi nous sommes
devenus de plus en plus productifs, car
sinon nous  ne sont pas comme Shiva avec
pas cent fois plus productifs parce que
nous avons cent paires de bras et
cent paires de jambes, je ne pense pas que l'
évolution soit importante, donc ce que nous faisons lorsque
nous utilisons de l'énergie, c'est que nous ajoutons à notre
corps un  exosquelette qui est quelques
centaines de fois plus puissant à l'heure où
nous parlons en ce moment la
puissance installée de toutes les machines sur terre des
bateaux aux ascenseurs et des aspirateurs
aux poêles est quelques centaines de fois
la puissance tueuse de la Meuse de l'humanité donc
ceux qui produisent  nos machines pas nous
nous ne faisons rien nous commandons des machines
mais sinon nous ne produisons pas la
capacité productive du monde ce sont des
machines donc les gens découvrent l'énergie et
ainsi ils sont capables de produire  e plus par
personne et extraire plus rapidement des ressources de
l'environnement, ils sont également capables d'
inventer du capital, ce qui est le moyen d'épargner
une partie du produit de la
production passée pour augmenter la
production future, c'est essentiellement ce que c'est du
capital, veuillez noter que lorsque vous utilisez plus
et plus d'énergie l'une des choses que
vous avez pu extraire plus rapidement de l'
environnement est la nourriture la productivité de l'
agriculture en France a été augmentée
de sept à huit entre 1945 et 1975
grâce aux combustibles fossiles à savoir les tracteurs les
engrais et les pesticides d'
accord donc extraire plus  et plus de nourriture nous
pouvons devenir de plus en plus nombreux avec de
plus en plus de machines donc extraire de plus
en plus de choses de l'environnement
transformer de plus en plus et un jour nous
sommes si nombreux et si productifs que
non seulement les stocks qui ne se renouvellent pas
s'épuisent mais les  les stocks qui pourraient se renouveler
commencent à s'épuiser aussi aujourd'hui, par exemple
le stock de
poisson commercial dans l'Atlantique nord
dépend de la s  ources cinq à dix
Stein plus bas qu'il y a un siècle,
vous connaissez tous l'histoire de la morue
au Canada qui a complètement disparu, de
sorte qu'un certain nombre de stocks disparaissent des forêts
dans le monde disparaissent etc etc et
au cours de cette activité productive
nous créons également un certain nombre de
sous-produits indésirables que nous appelons la pollution la
pollution est essentiellement tous les
sous-produits indésirables de notre activité que nous
créons sans la possibilité de l'éviter
comme par exemple lorsque vous brûlez des
combustibles fossiles vous créez un sous-produit qui est du
carbone co2  le dioxyde et vous ne pouvez tout simplement pas
éviter cela d'accord et que la pollution est constituée de
tous ces produits indésirables qui
s'inversent dans l'environnement et
diminuent la qualité ou la quantité
des ressources restantes, c'est ce qu'ils
appellent et ils peuvent diminuer la
qualité de ces ressources instantanément  ou
avec le laboratoire et généralement pour le co2, vous
avez un décalage car je ne sais pas combien de
personnes dans la salle connaissent le
temps de résidence du surplus de co2  une fois
dans les airs mais je vais rappeler
que parce que c'est assez important dans
notre discussion le jour où nous arrêtons les émissions
le jour où nous arrêtons les émissions d'accord un
siècle après un peu la moitié du
surplus de co2 planera encore au-dessus d'une
tête mille ans  après 20% de ce
surplus de co2 sera toujours dans l'air
dix mille ans après d'accord,
je pense que neuf dix pour cent de ce
surplus de co2 seront toujours au-dessus de notre tête,
ce qui signifie qu'il n'y a pas de
bouton de résultat concernant le
changement climatique là-bas  il n'y a absolument aucune
possibilité de remettre les choses en place
aucune possibilité et à cause de cette
inertie du co2 dans l'air la seule
chose que l'on peut déduire le jour où les
conséquences du changement climatique sont
insupportables c'est qu'elles
vont s'aggraver plus tard c'est la  seule
certitude que nous avons à cause de l'inertie
du co2 dans l'air, donc la pollution
est à nouveau des effets immédiats ou
des effets retardés de substances indésirables
dans l'environnement et ce que nous avons
conçu  quand on regarde le
système économique c'est une unité de flux qui est le PIB
comme vous le savez le PIB est la contrepartie
de la production de l'année c'est à dire
des chiffres économiques que l'on met sur le
flux physique que l'on crée chaque année en
extrayant des choses de l'environnement
et les convertir en d'autres choses
et nous faisons que même dans les services par
exemple l'éducation ne peut pas avoir lieu
sans construire sans que les gens se
rendent à l'endroit où il y a l'
éducation ou sans réseaux pour faire de
l'enseignement à distance mais quels réseaux comme il a
été dit par le secrétaire général  sont
encore pires que d'aller au lycée et en
fait je le rapport qui dit
qu'aujourd'hui le système numérique mondial émet
4% des émissions mondiales vient
de nous et qu'il augmente de 10%
par an donc vous n'avez rien de plus
insoutenable que l'économie numérique
rien donc ce que nous avons créé est ici
un indicateur qui mesure un flux
que nous avons appelé le PIB bien sûr
vous pouvez le comprendre  schéma très simple
qu'il n'y a pas de
croissance perpétuelle lorsque la production atteint des sommets
dans des stocks que nous connaissions ou qui ne peuvent pas se
renouveler aussi vite que nous l'utilisons et
lorsque le stock va
s'épuiser, nous allons manquer de stock bien sûr  le
flux va s'effondrer évident
on aurait dû concevoir une comptabilité
où on aurait compté avec un
chiffre positif ce qu'on a créé mais
avec un chiffre négatif ce qu'on a
détruit et le jour où la valeur marginale
de la dernière voiture est inférieure à la
marginale  valeur du minerai de fer, du
charbon et du pétrole, etc. que nous avons utilisés pour
fabriquer la voiture, nous avons arrêté de
fabriquer des voitures et vivons heureux pour
toujours avec les voitures que nous avons déjà,
désolé mes 10 minutes sont terminées,
je veux juste rappeler le
oh arrête ça
Je voulais juste rappeler un graphique du
rapport The Meadows précisément sur le
rapport au Club de Rome des limites
de la croissance comme vous le nommez car vous savez
que la pensée de l'économie physique
était en fait la  la grande
innovation de ce modèle la conception l'
économie est un système physique et ce
système physique est exactement comme je l'ai
décrit comme je l'ai décrié juste
avant c'est une question de flux et l'un de
ces flux a une contrepartie qui est en
dollars ou en euros  ou quoi qu'il en soit au
début de la simulation qu'ils
ont conçue disons au début
du 20ème siècle vous voyez que la
population est faible l'approvisionnement alimentaire est faible
le produit industriel est faible et les
ressources restantes sont très élevées alors au moment
de la sortie  du rapport,
tout grandissait en ce qui concerne les indicateurs
dont nous nous soucions, c'est-à-dire la population, la
production, l'agriculture, etc. et la
question des ressources n'était pas je
dirais dramatique alors jamais dit que le
système s'effondrerait dans 20 ou 30 ou 40
ans qui n'a jamais dit comme  J'ai lu
partout que l'approvisionnement en pétrole
disparaîtrait dans 30 ou 40 ans Je n'ai jamais dit
qu'en
fait, c'est que ce qu'ils ont dit, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui, les choses continueraient de croître s  o
dans le scénario business-as-usual aujourd'hui,
nous nous réunissons aujourd'hui, les choses continuent de
croître mais c'est pour après que les
choses vont que les temps difficiles
vont arriver et ils ont besoin de la
génération d'un enfant et de ma
génération pour le reste de  ma vie
va probablement être témoin d'un
nombre important de fissures et d'un
nombre croissant de fissures dans le système
ok donc les générations futures elles sont
nées aujourd'hui les générations futures elles
sont nées aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas pour l'
avenir elles sont nées aujourd'hui c'est le  les enfants
que vous voyez tous les jours à la maison donc c'est
ce que je voulais rappeler car comme cela a
été mentionné précédemment nous sommes
malheureusement toujours sur la bonne voie sur cette
simulation et donc c'est à ma
connaissance le meilleur modèle macroéconomique
que j'ai jamais vu car il est
prédictif  plus de 40 ans merci bien
merci jeune marque pour cette
présentation très instructive en tant qu'ancien
secrétaire général du Club de Rome
je suis très heureux d'avoir votre approbation
ce modèle de dépassement et d'effondrement pour
cela
merci bien je ne reviendrai pas au
début seulement pour dire que ce scénario
d'effondrement excessif comme vous le
dites à juste titre a été revu par des
experts indépendants pour voir où nous en sommes et
malheureusement nous suivons  ce scénario
assez précisément, mais je suppose que je
ne contesterais pas, mais j'aimerais juste
revenir sur un point que vous avez dit très
audacieusement, nous n'allons pas éviter l'
effondrement du système, c'est une remarque assez sérieuse,
je pense que beaucoup d'entre nous comprennent que nous
ne pouvons pas  résoudre nos problèmes dans le simple
sens de faire disparaître les problèmes,
ce dans quoi nous sommes maintenant consiste à
atténuer les dégâts et à obtenir
le meilleur résultat possible, nous devons
réfléchir à ce que nous entendons par effondrement parce que
nous n'avons pas discuté  que pourtant il y a
différents dans l'analyse des systèmes il y a
différents modes d'effondrement nous devons
penser ce que nous voulons dire mais en principe nous
espérons que nous n'avons pas à être d'accord avec
vous là-dessus et que nous pouvons trouver wa  oui pour
produire un monde décent, un monde digne
comme Albert l'a appelé malgré les
problèmes dont nous parlons, mais le
point qui est clair pour tout le monde est que
plus tôt nous commençons à agir, meilleures
seront les chances que nous arrivions maintenant à un  très
différent